whether you're a gigantic enterprise or
a small team at a startup or even a loan
developer
if you're using google cloud there's one
thing you all have in common
your project will use and depend on
service accounts
everyone uses them but what are they
what do they do
where do they come from and why should
you care
these are all important questions that
we have got to know the answers to
i'm here to help you figure out what's
what with service accounts
so service accounts what exactly are
they
to answer that let's take a look at
something you might already be familiar
with
a user account account represents jahira
the lead engineer on your team she
accesses the account with the email
address and password associated with it
and access to it is shared with no one
else
iam roles associated with it that
granted permission to do some
fun stuff like manage kubernetes
clusters create compute instances
and configure monitoring on the project
as long as jahira works on the team
she can do whatever the iim policy
allows
and if she leaves a team well her
account would be disabled so that it
couldn't be used anymore
that's a user account a service account
on the other hand
is an identity that a compute instance
or an application can use to run
api requests on your behalf are a few
major differences between a user account
and a service account
like jahira's user account a service
account has an assigned email
but instead of a password it can only be
authenticated using a private public rsa
key
pair and it can't be logged in via a
browser
accounts typically represent virtual
machines and applications
and while user accounts should never be
shared permission can be granted to
users to impersonate service accounts
allowing multiple users to access
everything that a service account can
access
accounts are granted iam roles to
perform certain actions
and access certain resources in your
project just like a user account
although they are usually executing
automated actions and might have
multiple processes dependent on them
that means you'll need to be extra
careful when you edit their access
or if you want to disable or delete them
two types of service accounts well first
there are google managed service
accounts
you might see these sometimes referred
to as service agents
these are service accounts that google
automatically creates and manages for
some google cloud services
for example right off the bat your
project is likely to have a google apis
service agent
this is a service account that runs
internal google processes on your behalf
there could be more google managed
service accounts that exist in your
project
but you'll only see them in your ian
policy
or audit logs when you enable an api or
a service that needs it
google managed service accounts you
technically can change and revoke their
roles
but that's generally not a great idea
because it could cause some services to
stop working correctly
second type of service account that we
have is a user managed service account
this is a service account that you
explicitly create using identity and
access management
you choose a name and the roles
associated with it yourself
into any that you create user managed
service accounts include default service
accounts
these are user managed service accounts
that are created when you use some
google cloud services that are meant to
help you to get started
a default service account is created for
app engine and any service that uses app
engine
and for compute engine and any service
that uses compute engine
for those default service accounts is
typically project number dash
compute developer.gserviceaccount.com
for compute engine and project id at
appspot.gservicecount.com for app engine
default service accounts are generally
granted the editor role on your project
for production workloads
this might be a bit much so it's
recommended that you create your own
service accounts for these services
and apply more restricted roles to them
how can we see these service accounts in
our google cloud project
if you want to see all of the user
managed service accounts that currently
exist
on your project you can use the google
cloud console under iam
or through a cli using the gcloud
command
the command gcloud im service accounts
list
will nicely list your user managed
service accounts display names
emails and whether they're disabled see
all of your service accounts including
google managed ones
the command gcloud project getin policy
followed by your project id
is your best bet this will spit out your
project's iam policy
the roles currently assigned to the
accounts on your project
this is going to include user accounts
user managed service accounts
and google managed service accounts as
long as they have roles assigned to them
i have only begun to scratch the surface
of service accounts here
there are still some other things worth
considering when we talk about service
accounts
in this series we're going to learn more
about creating them getting rid of them
effectively managing them properly
securing them and
using them for development if you like
this video hit subscribe or leave us a
comment below
see you next time
you